[Music]
doin Belle thank you for joining me and
20 minute leaders you know we're on
October
31st uh right now so we're about 24 days
into into the war um and uh we're we're
capturing this moment in time as looking
at into the investment in VC ecosystem
as an investor yourself with to now
Night Dragon and previously with G Lo
you're very much immersed in the startup
Nation ecosystem and the cyber security
and AI landscape you know the core and
the Beating Heart of of our industry and
so I'd love to capture some of your
thoughts as to what you're observing now
in the investment conversations that
investors have with entrepreneurs your
conversations with entrepreneurs how
they're thinking and um and we will of
course be sharing this after the War but
I love that we're capturing this during
the war so that we can really capture
the real time and feelings and
sentiments let's do it so first thank
you so much for having me I'm more than
happy to uh share a little bit about
what I'm seeing and what we as a fund
are seeing uh in Israel during this time
um you know I want to start first with
numbers for a second if you just look at
recent news things are not uh things are
still moving in Israel in terms of
Investments and in terms of Acquisitions
just today dig security was was
announced to be acquired by Palo Alto
for example we've had many other uh
Acquisitions that have happened in the
last few months but this one in
particular is very exciting because uh
it's happening now um we had Island that
that just announced a mega round of
investment a a week ago or something two
weeks ago so things are still moving um
I think you know for a while Market has
not been at its best obviously um and we
we all hoping to see uh the market
return to to higher levels by the end of
this year I think that the war may be
delayed it just just by a little bit um
but this doesn't have to do with just
Israel it's in general in general I
think the the that we were very
optimistic that it would rebound fully
by the end of this year and maybe it'll
happen in qm um now more so in terms of
what I'm see being right now during the
war post October
7th um for me meetings with companies
that I've already set that are already
happening you know Advanced
conversations are still happening I
think that israelies do what they do
best and that is be resilient and keep
things moving keep things going just you
know we were H we were talking about
business continuity and I think this is
the main topic of of
conversation um whereas you know a month
ago it's something that I wouldn't
really ask at least
initially um you know Founders need to
or have had to reassess who from their
organization was impacted by October 7th
you know who had family that was
murdered that was kidnapped who uh who
was impacted personally and then the
second question is who now is called to
reserves how many of our Workforce now
been out um what I'm seeing is uh from
the very small companies to the larger
companies with hundreds and thousands of
employees the number is around 20% of
the workforce has been called to
reserves um right now I think we have a
huge amount of of reservice on duty I'm
not sure and don't I don't know if I'm
right on this or not but it's going to
be quite difficult for us to maintain
having you know that those 400,000 uh
reservice on duty I don't know if the
number will kind of be dynamic that
maybe in a month from now uh if there's
no further escalations maybe the number
will kind of go a little bit down
because we're at over capacity but maybe
not it's it's really TVD but right now
we're dealing with around 20% of the
workforce uh has been called to reserve
duty just today I had uh a great
face-to-face meeting with CEO of a
company we're evaluating and you know he
worked all day as the CE of the company
and around 5 6: p.m. uh I asked him if
he could just give me a quick call and
he said that he's on his way to the base
and he'll call me later so what's
happening is people are working double
shifts like they're some of them that
are not full-time in on the ground are
doing their day jobs and are doing their
their reservist duties so it's something
that's very very admirable and very you
know inspiring to see uh all the
Israelis all of us come together and
help and and do whatever is needed to be
done uh for the country for the safety
of
everyone um so business continuity
continues to be kind of top of Mind
Founders are needing to understand who
from which team has been called to
reservice you know if um let's say I I
spoke to another founder like yesterday
and he was saying that 60% of his it
department has been called so at that
point and this was October 8th so the
day after 60% of the IT team is called
meaning what do we do so he looked at
his business continuity plan that he
already had and he had a list of vendors
that he was going to use and he just
chose one of the vendors and unworded uh
uh an Outsource vendor for it that's an
example of something that you know that
he was doing to continue things as usual
um other things that I I've heard of are
founders that are you know let's say
your VPS are out or some of the VPS are
out so you can create kind of smaller
teams where you assign uh um a specific
leader within these teams to take
decisions when the higher ups are out uh
but of course continue to keep
Management in the loop have syns
document everything so that everyone
stays align um and things like that
there's also within this business
continuity plan like worst case
scenarios right so what happens if the
all the internet in Israel goes down
what do we do so they have a solution
for that or what happens if we need
tomorrow to get all of our leaders out
of Israel so they have passports ready
they have relocation plans ready what
happens if the office gets bombed are is
all of our proprietary data in the cloud
where is it is it stored is it safe you
know so these are questions that are
being asked that Founders are asking
themselves even before investors are
asking them um and I think it's
something that that they've had prepared
for a while or at least they they will
now moving yeah moving on what has been
your experience with um International
investors their their experience with
what's happening what is their sort of
reaction to the space obviously they're
they're also asking questions they have
some some thoughts of their own but what
has been and and I'm sure that they're
also very you know concerned for the
well-being of the founds and the team
you know I have a lot of international
um us and and European investors in my
company and I've been astounded by the
care the empathy and um pretty much on a
daily basis and then there's still a
need for business continuity and there
an expectation with a fiduciary duty to
everybody that we we try to keep things
moving as as much as possible what has
been your experience like with
that okay so within n Dragon everyone is
extremely supportive you know Dave uh
the CEO my boss he's been working with
Israel for 25 years he loves Israel so
it's been very very uh heartwarming to
see all of the support I think generally
speaking and I've gotten you know
outreaches from tons and tons of
different International investors
International cesos Executives everyone
is worried everyone cares everyone shows
you know is asking what can they do
people that are former military in the
US are asking me if I can connect them
with someone in A200 so that they can
try and help and do something Beyond
just you know sending their well wishes
so it's been very
heartwarming um I think when it comes to
Investments like the general consensus
is that perhaps in the next couple of
weeks some international players will
kind of slow things down in
Israel um
we may see fewer deals happening just in
the very short term because people are
still kind of waiting to see what's
going to happen and I think that the
more Founders are resilient the the
shorter this time period will be um you
know one of the I spoke to a CEO uh who
was saying that his customers are
surprised that he's still reaching out
to them and still business as usual
because they don't expect so the more
that you know we Ain resilient the
shorter uh the the long-term impact will
be or the less the long-term impact will
be the shorter the TBD time will last
and the more things will just get back
to normal uh when it comes to
collaborations with the United States I
think the other point that I was going
to say is that perhaps the bar for
Israeli Founders will be higher than the
bar for for American companies I think
in general it's higher but now it's
going to be even more um and and but
just makes us just makes us work harder
and be better so and then that's and
that's why we went at the end I think
that what what what do a I want to
articulate that and leave and leave and
take away from this conversation is this
notion of um you know the the the fact
that this that how quickly this is this
integrates into our our our ability to
continue operating businesses usual this
sort of dance and Tango between the care
and the empathy and then and our duty
for the safety of our families and
neighbors and our country at the same
time our duty for continuing and being
and excelling as entrepreneurs and as
leaders in in different technological
domains around the world and we started
this conversation with providing some
some anecdotes of all these amazing
things are still happening even over the
last few weeks from fundraising to to
Acquisitions and and I you know the
sentiment that I've been Gathering as
well is that pretty much you know you
mentioning the different questions that
every CEO is now asking and those are
not questions that I think 99% of CEOs
around the world need to ask and at the
same time there is certainly continuity
um with it with almost everybody and I
think that it's if anything it just
makes this it makes the seos system
stronger in all these adversities
I 100% agree I think that you know this
is a great opportunity to to double down
you know whether it's Founders doubling
down or investors doubling down on
Israel so any company that right now
gets funding and I'm not saying it's
going to be so rare I'm just saying that
it speaks volumes if you're continuing
to get funding continuing as usual and
it also speaks volume for investors that
are doubling down in Israel during this
time this time when Israel needs them
the most um so it's it's not the time to
abandon deals that you were already in
the Pro in progress with it's the time
to double down on them um and and I
appreciate that at the end it's all it's
a long journey it's all about resiliency
and here is an opportunity for investors
to see how Founders and entrepreneurs
fair in some of the most difficult
adversities and you know it's you know
we all know that on that you know
building these startups is a is a roller
coaster ride and I can't think of many
more situ ations that are harder than a
war breaking out and a Founder that is
able to maintain Motivation Excellence
in business operations during this time
is probably a Founder that any
International investor should want to
back and so I think this is more than
anything going to be a testament for how
strong we are and and Rin I really want
to thank you for for the time and the
energy and I love how we're we're
capturing this at 24 days into the war
we're just you know hopefully not too
not too far away from the end of it but
but who knows and and um you know it's
been it's been a pleasure so thank you
very much yeah thank you so much and and
I will end by saying that you know
security and Cyber Solutions are
Israel's bread and butter right that's
what we're great at we're great at a lot
of things security is definitely one of
them and if anything this war is given
an opportunity for new technologies to
be created for things that were
operational to now be used um you know
was creating a lot of uh uh need for the
fight against misinformation and the
fight against fishing hacks and all
these things because we're not just
fighting this physical War we're also
fighting a psychological war and a cyber
war and all of these things just give
opportunity for us to continue what we
do 100% 100
100% H couldn't say it better thank you
so much do